ARE GOING TO BE CALLED TO
ACCOUNT AS THE HISTORY IS READ
ON THIS.
DR. ATLAS, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BAD ENOUGH THAT MILLIONS OF KIDS
ARE NOT IN THE CLASSROOM, BUT
WHAT IF SOME SCHOOLS ACTUALLY
MAKING MONEY OFF THIS TRAVESTY.
DOMINIC?
ACCORDING TO A SOON TO BE
RELEASED REPORT OBTAINED BY
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE," SOME OF
PENNSYLVANIA’S LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE ON TRACK TO DO
JUST THAT.
IN FACT, DISTRICTS IN
HARRISBURG, PHILLY, AND
PITTSBURGH IMPROVED THEIR BUDGET
SITUATIONS THANKS TO GENEROUS
HANDOUTS FROM THE FEDS, AND
THAT’S DESPITE TAX REVENUES
DECLINING DUE TO THE GOVERNOR’S
COVERT DICTATES.
AND THEY’RE ABOUT TO GET EVEN
MORE NOW FROM THE
1.000000000000 -- $9 TRILLION
TRAVESTY IN THE COVID RELIEF
BILL.
NOW, THE PHILADELPHIA SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALONE COULD END UP WITH
$600 MILLION MORE THAN THEY HAD
IN 2019.
JOINING US NOW IS JENNIFER
STEPHANO, THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE COMMONWEALTH FOUNDATION.
IT JENNIFER, THINK PARENTS
WATCHING THIS, STEAM IS COMING
OUT OF THEIR EARS.
THE SCHOOL COULD SEE THEIR
FUNDING INCREASE DESPITE NOT
BEING OPEN FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING.
>> CORRECT.
ACROSS PENNSYLVANIA, SCHOOLS ARE
NOT OPENING, THEY ARE NOT GOING
BACK FULL-TIME AND AS A PARENT
OF SCHOOL-AGED CHILDREN, YEAH,
STEAM IS COMING OUT OF MY EARS.
AND THE TEACHERS UNION BOSSES,
ALONG WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
SPEAKER PELOSI AND THE
PENNSYLVANIA GOVERNOR CONTINUE
TO PUSH A NARRATIVE THAT THEY
NEED MORE MONEY TO OPEN.
THIS IS -- PUSHING A BIG LIE.
IT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE AND
THERE’S TWO REASONS FOR IT.
NUMBER ONE, DISTRICTS ACROSS
PENNSYLVANIA, 95% OF THEM ARE
FISCALLY SOUND.
THE STATE GOVERNMENT NEVER
CAUGHT 1 PENNY, NOT 1 PENNY FROM
EDUCATION FUNDING DESPITE MANY
SCHOOLS NOT REOPENING.
NUMBER TWO, WHEN THE FED
STIMULUS PACKAGE CAME IN THE
FIRST TIME AROUND, SCHOOL
DISTRICT LIKE THE CITY OF
PHILADELPHIA INCREASED EVEN
THEIR RESERVE FUNDING.
THEY COULD HAVE AN EXTRA
$600 MILLION ON HAND AND THEY
HAVEN’T OPENED THEIR DOORS.
AND HERE’S THE BIG THING THOUGH,
LAURA.
IN THE MARKETPLACE, IN
INNER-CITY PHILADELPHIA,
CATHOLIC SCHOOLS ARE OPEN.
THE CATHOLIC SCHOOLS -- THEY ARE
SAFELY EDUCATING CHILDREN, AND
THEY ARE DOING SO WITH BETTER
RESULTS AND AT A FRACTION OF THE
COST, WHICH THEY WERE DOING
BEFORE COVID, AND THEY ARE IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE -- YOU
KNOW, THE TEACHERS UNION BOSSES
LEFT TO SAY PRIVATE SCHOOLS
AREN’T IN CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS.
FALSE, THE CATHOLIC SCHOOLS IN
PHILADELPHIA GO WHERE NO ONE
ELSE WILL.
THEY ARE IN THE POOREST
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS IN THE
COUNTRY, WHICH IS IN
PHILADELPHIA.
THEY ARE THERE SERVING THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
>> Laura: THIS IS A SCAM.
LET ME JUST SAY, THIS IS A SCAM
FOR THE TEACHERS UNIONS.
THEY ARE RUNNING A SCAM ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY AND PARENTS -- YOU
KNOW, ALL THESE LIBERAL PARENTS
OUT THERE, DONALD TRUMP IS THE
WORST THING EVER, I’M NOT GOING
TO VOTE AGAINST TRUMP -- ARE YOU
HAPPY NOW?
ARE YOU THRILLED THAT THIS IS
WHAT YOU GOT?
BECAUSE I DON’T THINK THEY’RE
GOING TO BE OPENING IN THE FALL
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
WHEN I HEARD NANCY PELOSI SAY
THAT THING ABOUT THE VARIANCES
TODAY, WELL, WE GOT TO CHECK
WITH WITH THE VARIANCES TO SEE
IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
COVID RELIEF BILL, WHY WOULD SHE
BE TALKED ABOUT A COVID RELIEF
BILL A THIRD TIME AROUND IF THEY
WERE GOING TO OPEN THE
BUSINESSES IN THE SCHOOLS?
I FOUND THAT VERY DISTURBING.
>> YOU SHOULD BE DISTURBED, WE
ALL SHOULD BE DISTURBED AND I
THINK YOU CANNOT BLAME THIS ON A
PAST PRESIDENT ANYMORE AND I
THINK PARENTS, WHETHER LIBERAL,
CONSERVATIVE, YOU HAVE GOT TO
REALIZE THAT THE POWER IS OUT OF
YOUR HANDS.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK IF
I CAN JUST GET THESE KIDS BACK
IN SCHOOL, BUT NEVER FORGET THE
POWER THE TEACHERS UNION BOSSES
HAVE EXERTED OVER YOU AND YOUR
CHILDREN ’SLIDES, AND THAT
SHOULD BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
WE NEED TO GET PROGRESSIVE ABOUT
EDUCATION IN AMERICA.
MONEY SHOULD FOLLOW THE CHILD.
PERIOD.
>> Laura: WE SHOULD CHANGE THE
WAY WERE THINKING ABOUT THIS.
PRIVATE AND PAROCHIAL SCHOOLS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN AT RISK
AREAS CAN OPEN AND KIDS ARE
LEARNING, WHY THE HELL AREN’T WE
DOING THAT ACROSS THIS COUNTRY?
VIRGINIA, PENNSYLVANIA, WHERE
KIDS AREN’T IN SCHOOL FIVE DAYS
A WEEK.